>> Becky Baines:
Cold-- ah, sorry--
it was a cold mic for a second
but-- I think we're good to go.
Hi guys. Good morning.
How's everybody doing?
Pretty good?
My name is Becky Baines, and
I'm the Editorial Director
and Vice President of National
Geographic kid's books.
First, I would like to thank
the Library of Congress so much
for sponsoring this
wonderful event.
Are you guys having fun?
Yes, yes. So, if you
haven't had a chance yet,
I encourage everybody to stop
by our booth, which is S3,
where you can do some
really cool code breaking.
There's virtual reality,
where you can travel
to the Arenal rain forest.
And of course, you can meet
our author, who you'll be dying
to meet after this presentation.
So, I just want to give
you a little background.
As an organization, we pride
ourselves on bringing facts,
photos, fun, and all
things animal to kids.
Or you guys familiar
with our animal books?
Yeah? So, when we decided
to get into fiction,
it's not something we
decided to do lightly.
And actually, this is something
five years in the making now.
But somewhere along the line,
we realized that we have all
these super cool explorers,
we have all these
amazing adventure stories,
we have access to all this
really cool technology.
And what if we could take
all that stuff and put it
in a fictional world,
where you guys, the kids,
are at the center of the action?
Does that sound cool?
So, we had this concept.
And we decided, okay,
we're going to make
this Explorer Academy.
And it's a school where kids
can travel the world on a ship,
they can dive with whales, they
can uncover ancient artifacts,
they can scale mountains,
they can scale glaciers.
And you can basically see
all this amazing planet has
to offer.
So, what we needed next
was an author, right?
You need someone to write it.
So, we had all this cool
stuff, and we needed someone
who could take it and intertwine
in with a super cool kid heroes,
top secret missions,
ancient codes and ciphers,
and of course, a villainous
organization who's always
out to get them, right?
Because you always
need a bad guy.
So, there is so many twists and
turns in this story, you guys.
Once you start reading, you
will not be able to stop.
So, I am so pleased
that a journalist
turned TV News reporter,
turn the TV weather woman,
turned children's author
actually answered our call.
Trudi Trueit has brought
awe inspiring science tech
and adventure of National
Geographic two life
in this pages turning
Explorer Academy.
The first book is
'The Nebula Secret'.
Through these fun, funny,
brilliant characters.
And she created this
incredible futuristic world
where it all takes place.
And once you read it, you guys
will imagine yourselves right
at the center of the action.
And if you guys liked
which you see up here,
I have a secret for you.
This book actually doesn't
go on sale until Tuesday,
but back at the bookstore,
we have some exclusive copies
that you guys can pick up today.
And you can get it
signed by our author.
Oh, we have one right there.
You can get it signed
by our author,
who will be at the
signing booth at 12:30.
So don't miss out
on that opportunity.
So, without further ado,
I'd like to present our
author, Trudi Trueit.
[ Applause ]
>> Trudi Trueit: Hi, everyone.
Are you having a
good time today?
Oh, it's so exciting for
me to be here and to talk
about Explorer Academy.
It is a series of seven books.
And the first one will be
coming out September 4,
but you guys get it today.
And I wanted to start with a
little video of why I wanted
to write for National
Geographic,
as if you needed to know.
But let's play that.
>> Trudi Trueit: No?
No video. Okay, we'll
move along.
There you go.
Okay, so this is me when
I was eight years old.
And I might not look
like it at the time.
Because, you know, cat's
eye glasses weren't popular,
not like they are now.
But I loved reading and writing.
And how many of you guys
love reading and writing too?
Put up your hands.
Let's see how many.
Oh, we have lots of
readers, wonderful.
So, I started writing plays
when I was in the fourth grade.
And I realized the
power words over people,
that you could write words and
impact people and evoke emotion
and share your passion.
And that's what I started doing.
And then I became a journalist.
And I worked as a TV
reporter for a while,
and also a weather anchor.
That's why I keep wanting
to do this all the time.
But, so I started
writing children's books
because I would go
around to schools
and I would talk
about the weather.
And we would talk about
clouds and rain and rainbows,
and how the weather worked.
And I loved talking to
classes so much that I decided
to write a weather book.
And I submitted it,
and of course,
Nobody really wanted
to publish it.
But, Scholastic came to me
and said, 'How would you
like to write four
weather books?'
And I said I would
love to do that.
So, I started writing
nonfiction.
And you may know
of me, hopefully,
from nonfiction books
in your library.
If you go back to your school
library, look up my name and see
if you can find some
of my nonfiction work.
Because I've done everything
from animals to health
to wildlife to video games.
I can even show you how to make
things out of Popsicle sticks
to give your mom
for Mother's Day.
And along that same route, I
also started doing fiction,
and I wrote a couple
of fiction series,
one of them called 'Julep
O' Toole' and 'Secrets
of a Lab Rat' was the
second series that I wrote.
And I wrote those for
Simon and Schuster.
And it was just such a
wonderful opportunity to be able
to do both fiction
and nonfiction.
And I did that for
the longest time.
So, when National
Geographic came along,
it was the perfect
opportunity to take what I knew
about writing nonfiction and
when I knew about fiction
and put them together.
So, let me tell you a little
bit about Explorer Academy.
Explorer Academy is the story
of 12 year old Cruz Coronado.
And he has been accepted into
a very elite school for tours.
And he's going to
travel around the world,
learning about all different
kinds of issues and things
that are going on in the world.
He's going to travel to faraway
places and talk to animals
and get involved in
preserving the earth.
And he's going to do it
with 23 very good friends.
And along the way,
Cruz has a mystery
that he's going to solve.
And you, as the reader, are
going to help him solve it.
Because you get to
crack the clues
and the puzzles along with Cruz.
So now I have a book trailer.
Let's see if we can
watch the book trailer.
Still nothing?
No, we don't even have a book
[inaudible] I'm so sorry.
If you go to my website,
truditreuit.com,
you can watch the book trailer
because it is so amazing.
Alright, so what inspired
me to write this series?
Well, really it was
the explorers
of National Geographic.
All the archeologists
and the marine biologists
and the scientists of National
Geographic inspired me.
Now in the book, Cruz
and his friends get
to do augmented reality.
So, you know what that is?
That's like virtual reality.
They get to go to what's
called a computer animated
virtual experience.
And they get to explore things
without really ever
leaving home.
And that's how they
learn how to train.
And so, I had to create
some interesting things
for Explorer Academy.
And one of those things that I
thought would be fun would be--
because I wore glasses
as a kid and I still do--
glasses that change color
and shape with your emotion.
So, I see a few kids
here wearing glasses.
Can you imagine what it would
be like if you were angry
and your glasses got red and
started, you know, spewing fire?
And I thought this would
be really fun to do.
And what I found out
is that explorers
at National Geographic are
already doing something very
similar to that.
There are scientists that are
already working on materials
that can actually change color
and shape and texture based
on your environment and
based on h ow you feel.
And say if it's raining outside,
you could actually have a coat
that automatically
opens on its own.
So, I found some pretty amazing
technology is already happening
right now.
It's not even science fiction.
So, Cruz has a honeybee
drone, and her name is Mel.
And she goes with
him everywhere.
And again, I thought,
well, you know,
there's still a little
bit science fiction.
But in actuality, scientists
are already doing this.
They are already developing--
you see on the left-hand side--
there already developing
tiny drones.
And these drones can go into
places that people can't go.
Like to search and rescue
and to earthquake areas.
They're also used
for medical purposes.
So, science and science
fiction isn't that far apart.
So, one of the key elements
of Explorer Academy is
Cruz's mother was working
on a secret formula
when she was killed
in a mysterious lab accident.
And I decided to use what
I knew about snake venom
and scorpion venom
and animal venoms
in general as a key plot point.
Because we're using those for
medicinal purposes in science.
And one of the explorers
that helped me with that,
his name is Zoltan Takacs.
And Zoltan is here today.
So, if you head on over
to the National Geographic
booth this afternoon, at 2:30
and 4:00, were going to do a
little presentation together.
He will talk about
all things snakes,
which kind of scares me a little
bit, but I only have to write
The material, I don't
have to hold the snakes.
So, a little behind the
scenes of Explorer Academy.
We tried a couple of
different covers and this is--
the big one on the right--
that's the one we chose based
on what you guys liked and what
we thought really represented
action and adventure
in Explorer Academy.
And I kind of like
that cover too.
And one of the things
I do when I write,
is I tent to doodle
the characters.
So, I have a little
bulletin board
where I put the characters up.
And so, those are my doodles
of the main characters.
And you can see what our
illustrator, Scott Plumbe did.
His illustrations are
much better than mine.
And there's lots of
illustrations in the book.
And what's really cool
about it is, there's plenty
of places for imagination.
But he's also done a
really terrific job
at illustrating throughout
the book as well.
So those are the
main characters.
Cruz is the big picture,
and then his friends.
Emmet is on the right.
Lonnie is on the top.
And then Sailor is
on the bottom.
I also had to draw a boat.
Because in book two,
the explorers head
off around the world.
So that's my drawing
of the boat.
And again, take a look
at Scott's illustration
in the book.
So much better than mine.
So, with Explorer
Academy, my goal really was
to tell a great adventure story,
have you guys been excited
about exploring in the world,
and finding maybe
even your passion.
Because maybe one
of you guys sitting
out there is the
next great scientist
to discover something
amazing and to get involved
in conservation issues and to
make difference in the world.
Because the future is really
what you guys make of it.
So, that's Explorer Academy.
And do you guys have
questions for me?
I think we have microphones,
right?
So, if you head out to the
side and you can ask a question
about Explorer Academy
or reading or science.
Oh, we have a few questions.
Yeah?
>> Who's your favorite
character in Explorer Academy?
>> Trudi Trueit: Oh, you know,
actually my favorite character
is the honeybee drone.
Because her name is
Mel and she gets Cruz
out of a lot of trouble.
So, he gets stuck in some places
and Mel comes along
and saves him.
My human favorite character
this probably his best friend,
Lonnie.
She didn't get accepted into
the academy in the first book,
so she has to-- they
converse long distance.
But she helps him out
of a lot of trouble.
And she also eventually
will be able to make her way
into the academy, which, you
guys only know that first
because most people
don't know that.
Yeah, thank you for
the question.
Yeah?
>> What's your favorite
that you created
and is there any competitions?
>> Trudi Trueit: Is
there any competitions?
You mean write the book?
>> No, where do you
get the books?
>> Trudi Trueit: Where
do I get my ideas?
>> Yeah.
>> Trudi Trueit: Well, you know,
I get my ideas from
a lot of places.
I'm really a Star Trek geek
and I love science fiction.
I love adventure stories.
And, of course, I
give my inspiration
from the National
Geographic explorers.
If you go to the National
Geographic's website--
>> My friend Alex, her mom works
at National Geographic
in Washington, DC.
>> Trudi Trueit: Oh,
that's wonderful.
>> And one last thing.
Who is your illustrator?
>> Trudi Trueit: My illustrator,
his name is Scott Plumbe.
And he is from Vancouver
British Columbia I think.
I think he's from Canada.
He's really good.
I really like his work.
>> I like mythology.
>> Trudi Trueit: Thank
you for your question.
>> So, what inspired you to
write about the new book?
>> Trudi Trueit: What
inspired me to write what book?
>> About the book that
you were showing us.
>> Trudi Trueit:
What inspired me?
Well, there's so many things.
I love adventure stories.
And so, when I was a kid, I used
to read all kinds of adventure.
I love science fiction.
I love being able to--
I love animals too.
So, it's a great fun
to be able to bring all
of those things together and
just, you know, have the kids go
out on an amazing
adventure together and learn
about the world and
discover new animals.
I mean, that's so
inspiring to me.
But what the real National
Geographic explorers do,
that really inspires me.
>> The honeybee drone, Mel,
really made me remember
something about drones
that they are trying to make
as spies, pets for people
who can't really have
pets, like living animals.
>> Trudi Trueit:
Robotics is really huge.
Yeah. And it's amazing what
they're doing in the field
of drones, robotics,
all the things that--
I mean, some of the technology
in the book, I used the power
of your mind to do things.
There is-- they have
mind control cameras.
So, you put a tiny
little camera in front
of your eyes then you
take a picture based
on what you say in your brain.
We're really actually
not that far away
from doing things like that.
So that's pretty cool.
Thanks for your question.
>> Have you ever read a book
about the Galápagos Island?
>> Trudi Trueit: About
what, the Galápagos?
>> Yeah.
>> Trudi Trueit: You
know, I haven't written
about the Galápagos islands,
but I have written books
about snakes, alligators,
turtles, reptiles, octopuses.
My biggest book, one
of my biggest sellers,
in a book on octopuses.
They have all this strange,
weird octopuses that are
out there in the world.
So, I love wildlife
and I love nature.
One of the Explorer Academy
books will be devoted
to ocean life.
So, they just spend
the whole time
in the ocean under the water.
And I'm hoping that they
can swim with the turtles
and have a good time doing that.
Yeah.
>> Well I like reading
Nat Geo kids.
And I notice some of
your work is in there.
I read a sneak peek.
>> Trudi Trueit: Thank you.
>> And I'm just wondering,
did you write the bits
for Nat Geo kid's magazine?
>> Trudi Trueit: I
may have had a hand
in writing a little bit of it.
I only did an interview
with them, but I think most
of that was probably
written by the staff,
may be taking some
things from the book.
We kind of worked together
on some of the items.
But did you-- you saw the
issue where it had all
of the sneak peek of the
Explorer Academy and all that?
>> Yeah, I really liked that.
>> Trudi Trueit: Thank you.
I hope you like the book too.
Thanks for your question.
>> What inspired
you to write books?
>> Trudi Trueit: What
inspired me to write books?
I just loved reading as a kid.
And so, when I was your age,
I read, and read, and read.
And I used to bring home a stack
of books from the library so big
that I could barely fit
them into my backpack.
And I always have loved books.
I didn't always know that
I would write for children.
But when I got a chance
to go visit classrooms
as a weather forecaster,
you guys always had
such great questions, and
you are always so fascinated
and curious, that I just had to.
I just had to start
writing for children.
I just love two write for kids.
Thank you.
Good question.
>> How long did it take
you to write the book?
>> Trudi Trueit: It
took about six months.
And we're releasing a
book every six months.
So, I have to keep moving.
But the second book
will be out next spring.
And then the third book will
be out the following fall.
So, about five to six months.
>> Okay.
>> Trudi Trueit: Good
question, thanks.
>> What was your first
book that you wrote?
>> Trudi Trueit: My first
book was the one that was
up here called, 'Clouds', that
I showed in the beginning.
It was all about
different cloud formations
and how the clouds are formed.
And then I wrote about three
other books for Scholastic
on storm chasing and water
cycle and rain, hail,
and snow so that kids who
went to the library to learn
about weather or if you
wanted to write a report,
you could check out
one of my books.
So that was the first
book I ever wrote.
Then I was hooked.
>> How did you organize your
ideas for the first book?
>> Trudi Trueit: Good question.
So, what I like to do is, I
like to outline the story.
And I get an idea, and I
actually where I want each book
to go so that I know throughout
the series what is going
to happen in every book.
And then I do a more intense
outline for the first book.
Kind of where I want it to
start, how I want it to end,
and then where I want the kids
to be in the middle of the book.
And then you just sit down
every day and you write.
And sometimes, the characters
tell you different things,
they go different places, they
have different ideas than you,
and I have to let them be
who they are.
But it does help
to have an outline.
Because then I know where I
want to start and pretty much
where I want to finish up too.
Thanks for your question.
>> Did you get tired
of writing books?
>> Trudi Trueit: Did I what?
>> Get tired of writing books?
>> Trudi Trueit: Tired
of writing-- oh, no.
I never get tired
of writing books.
I get tired of other things
like deadlines when I have
to turn the book in if I
don't get done in time.
But I never get tired
of writing books.
I hope I'm writing
books forever.
Yeah, I love books.
As long as you guys keep
reading, we're good.
>> How much books do you have?
>> Trudi Trueit: How
many books do I have?
I have over 100 books in print.
I think the Explorer Academy
is 103 but I'm not sure.
I kind of figured I'd
stop counting at 100.
So, most of them are nonfiction.
But I have about
nine that are fiction
and Explorer Academy
is the tenth.
And I love, like I said, I love
nonfiction, I love learning.
So, it's great to
be able to do both.
Good questions.
>> What's your favorite
sea creature?
>> Trudi Trueit: My
favorite sea creature?
I'm going to go-- it's a tossup
between the Dumbo octopus
and the Vampire squid.
But I like them both.
I like octopuses a lot.
Because they're really smart
and they're clever
and they're creative.
And when I was doing my book on
octopuses-- I'm from Seattle.
And I went to a Seattle aquarium
and I talked to a biologist.
And he told me just how
smart the octopuses were
at the aquarium.
He said that they had
an octopus name Clyde.
And they noticed that
the other exhibits
around Clyde seemed
to be disappearing.
The other fish and
the crab were missing.
And they put a camera on Clyde
and they realized Clyde was
leaving his exhibit at night
and going into the other
exhibits and eating them.
And that's when I realized that
these animals are really cool.
They're very clever,
they're very smart.
They can open jars.
My sister is a diver
and she went diving once
and an octopus came along
and took her flashlight
and swam away with it.
She never saw it again.
It just went away.
So, I love octopuses a lot.
I have to figure out a way to
get them into Explorer Academy.
So, I have a couple
minutes left.
Are there more questions?
>> What's your favorite
part about creating a book?
>> Trudi Trueit:
My favorite part
about creating a book really
is starting with page one.
I love a blank page.
Because at that point,
you can do anything.
You can have the
characters go anywhere,
say anything, do anything.
And it's exciting to me
to write that first page.
I love that part.
The hardest part-- because I bet
you're going to ask that too--
is ending a series
or ending a book.
It's hard to say
goodbye to characters
that you spent so
much time with.
Good questions, you guys.
Yeah?
>> What's your favorite
book you've made?
>> Trudi Trueit:
My favorite book?
Well, I have to say
Explorer Academy.
Usually the book
that I'm working
on now is my favorite book.
And I love Explorer Academy
because it combines all the
things that I love to do.
In nonfiction and fiction,
and adventure and science.
It's a perfect combination
for me.
I love doing Explorer Academy.
>> What inspired
you to write books?
>> Trudi Trueit: So many things.
I just really enjoy words.
I enjoyed telling stories.
My parents can tell you I
was telling them stories
when I was really young,
and they were really
tired of hearing it.
But I just love storytelling.
I love reading.
And to be able to do an
adventure series is so exciting.
I'm, you know, thrilled
to be able to do that.
>> Thank you.
>> Trudi Trueit:
You're very welcome.
Thank you.
>> What challenges did you
face writing this book?
>> Trudi Trueit: Good question.
There were a lot of challenges
in writing an adventure
because you want it to be fast
paced, really interesting.
You want them to go
through a lot of challenges.
But at the same time,
you want to be able
to develop the characters too
and have good relationships
and good friendships.
So, yeah, it is, at times it
can be a challenge to make sure
that you have a lot of action.
Because you don't
want it to be boring.
But you also want the
characters to develop
and get to know one another.
And so, pacing a book can be
a little bit of a challenge.
That's a really good question.
So, I want to make sure
I'm not going too fast.
But you also don't
want to go too slow.
So, you find kind of
that middle ground
where you're telling
the story at a good pace
and allowing the
characters to develop
and have relationships
with each other.
So, yeah. That's
always a challenge,
pacing is a big challenge
in a book.
>> How many books will be in
the Explorer Academy series?
>> Trudi Trueit: We're planning
for seven books in the series.
And the first book, you
know, is coming out now.
The second book will
be out next spring.
And so, every six months, we
will release another book.
And right now, I'm working
on book number four.
So, you can tell, I'm already
halfway through the series.
So, thank you for coming.
Do you have closing--
>> Becky Baines: I was
just going to say that I'm
so sorry we ran out
of time for questions.
But Trudi will be at the
signing booth at 12:30.
So if you have any
more questions,
she's happy to answer them.
And also, she'll l be at our
booth all day, which is S3.
She'll be doing mini
presentations
up on our stage in there.
So, feel free to come by
and talk to her anytime.
>> Trudi Trueit: Yeah and
thank you so much you guys.
Come on by, say hi let
me know what you think.
[ Applause ]